whether you're dangling from the tallest
building in the world or
souping up a honda civic in a back alley
garage today's show has something for
every action-adventure fan
hi folks mark ellis here and it's time
to settle the score that's so
top secret it's been a code red
confidential need to know basis since
double secret probation was invented
that's right on this episode of versus
it's victorious vehicles up against
stupendous stunts put the diesel in
cruise control because it's the fast and
furious franchise
taking on the mission impossible film
series and an all-out bout of cinematic
super agent supremacy in one corner you
have ethan hunt and his merry nation of
rogues fallouts and protocol-minded
ghosts
in the other it's dom toretto and his
family of misfits nerdy wells and double
crossing backstabbers
your mission should you choose to accept
it is right along with me as we pour it
from zero to 60 and under 12
parsecs and i'm being told now that's
not a reference to any of these films
well yet we do have two action
blockbuster franchises and 15 total
movies
but only six will emerge victorious or
nine depending on
which series is the winner and by this
time next year probably going to be like
17 total flicks well to do the whole
thing again
i gotta go to the dry cleaners here's
how we'll determine a winner
round one box office round two tomato
meter slash
audience score round three characters
round four robin is racing and then
we'll do a wild card round that tom
cruise is hoping involves how many ribs
you've donated to the cause
will a fast franchise furiously charge
into a victory
or will it peter out after a quarter
mile and give way to the radical
sprinting ability of the impossible
missions
this is gonna get violent isn't it what
are you smiling about
dude almost had you what are you talking
about
this is not gonna end well round one box
office
let's kick off this round on a unifying
positive note
both of these franchises feature no
superheroes no comic book villains or
spaceships shuttling through a faraway
galaxy yet they've been consistently
dominating the box office since
in mission impossible's case 1996.
audiences worldwide have been likewise
lining up to see the fast and the
furious films
since 2001 but it was the star power of
tom cruise that got his franchise out to
the quickest start
the very first mission really really
tough is still the overall breadwinner
when we adjust for inflation
it did 970 million dollars worldwide
and while the bulk of that success is no
doubt linked to emilio estevez's
appearance
tom and his movies would go on to
average 815 million dollars per flick
with a third installment
being the low tide with the only 579
million dollars for its haul
and in case you're wondering mi2 did 950
million dollars of total business
meaning 20 million dollars worth of fans
were like me
and were still sour over emilio's demise
in the first act
but we did get metallica doing i
disappear for part two so
i guess i'll get over it eventually
well if you like heavy metal as in
literal actual metal
the rubber meets the road with the fast
and furious flicks today we've gotten
nine total movies and business is a lot
better for the most recent three films
than it was for the original trilogy the
first movie raked in just 344 million
dollars worldwide and tokyo drift which
is the third
talkie in the slate grossed only 227
million dollars
only you know crunching these numbers is
fun until you glance at your own wells
fargo account
then you go with that negativity
but once fast five hit the series
shifted into high gear and catapulted
its overall average
to 745 million dollars per outing with
furious 7 being the all-time champ
grossing 1.65 billion dollars
internationally what might be most
impressive is that the spin-off film
hobson shaw did 759 million dollars
even though it starred two characters
who were nowhere to be seen in the first
handful of furious movies
it helps that said characters are played
by the rock and jason statham but that's
still noteworthy i doubt mission
impossible could generate that kind of
business
if tom cruise handed the reins to simon
pegg and michelle monahan for an entire
movie
i mean i'd see it especially if emilio
comes back
look let's just say this if emilio
estevez was killed off in a fast and
furious movie
he'd already be somehow back in the fold
that's how they play ball
so mission impossible is winning the
wall of averages both domestically and
overall
but the box office potential of fast and
furious
appears to have a much higher ceiling no
mission flick has ever gotten over the
billion dollar mark
furious has done it twice those two
movies the back to back seventh and
eighth in order of release
no doubt gave us the feels due to the
tragic death of star paul walker but it
also
acts as a display of staying power the
furious franchise keeps trending
up over time furthermore it features
three
of the top five total earners in either
film set mission impossible
has been in the lexicon for decades and
has knocked out six movies in 25 years
with another on the way
but could it keep delivering its usual
numbers at the multiplex
if it had made nine movies in just two
decades
it is amazing that fast and furious has
lasted this long
without any prior brand name recognition
behind it
even more impressive is that it keeps
elevating to new
rarefied air look i'd love to see these
two franchises either team up
or go head to head during the same
opening weekend but as of now
i have to give the win to the fast and
the furious in this round
toretto family one hunt gaggle zero
salute me familiar
round two tomato meter slash audience
score
rare is the action film that all movie
goers can agree on as being superb
even more uncommon is a thrilling
franchise that both critics and
audiences can uniformly say is super
fresh
in terms of reception the most
impressive thing about both the fast and
the mission impossible films
is that the tomato meter and audience
score are pretty good friends throughout
the respective chronology
of the super spy endeavors however each
franchise took very different routes to
end up where we currently sit
now put your blouse back on hater
starting with the tomato meter the
double f
movies have acted like one of their
exciting and super illegal street races
it ain't how you start it's how you
finish the very first four fast and
furious movies
are all rotten with the fourth
installment being the weakest of the
pack at just
29 but then fast five showed up
crushed at the box office and hit the
nitrous on the tomato meter
to reach 77 fresh and
every film in the set has since remained
just as good smelling
furious 7 leads the way with a standard
setting 81
not even mission impossible can say it
has a film on the tomato meter in the
80s
but they do have three in the 90s the
most recent three movies are as follows
ghost protocol and rogue nation parts
four and five according to my mom
are twins at 93 percent then fallout
went and topped them both with a
sterling 97 percent
still the entire six film run averages
out to solid freshness
at 79 percent versus furious's 57
percent
in fact mission impossible 2 is the only
rotten movie in the series at 57 percent
but again that's the one with a
metallica song do we have rotten
tomatoes for music
no okay i'm starting a music one let's
call it um
spoiled carrots so as far as critics go
it would appear mission impossible is
cruising okay you saw where i was going
to another victory in this round but
wait wait wait that's
good god that's the audience scores
music
and using that metric the tom the stunt
guy movies
lose a significant amount of luster
fallout and rogue nation still top the
list
but they're only at 88 and 87 percent
and ghost protocol clocks in at number
three with 76
what 76 the guy climbs a gigantic
building you can see from space
and then falls into a sandstorm and you
people can't even give them a c
plus blue is glue and when it's red
well to be fair he almost plummeted to
his demise climbing rocks in part two
and that's got a rotten audience scored
43 percent
the other two flicks limp into fresh
town but the door has been left ajar
for vin paul michelle dwayne
turles idris jason sung kurt tyrese
okay you get the picture there's a lot
of people in those movies the fast and
furious films enjoy the better audience
score average
winning a tough victory over mission
impossible by a score of 74 percent
to 72 percent i chalk most of that up to
the audience
including this idiot talking
understanding nothing about what's
happening in part one of mission
impossible
at all like still to this day we're
breaking into langley
it's fun we steal a floppy disk and then
i get a headache
oh what's the matter you you've never
seen this trick
meanwhile only too fast too furious is
rotten on the audience score
mustering just 50 percent despite its
convenient to type title
it's surprisingly hobbs and shaw that is
the high mark for either franchise here
notching 88 that's just one measly
percentage above rogue nation and
fallout okay
yeah all told these numbers are
screaming that the audience approves of
everything they see
hear and promise not to attempt at home
on the big screen and that approval
rating is only getting better but from
start to finish it's mission impossible
that has created a chasm on the tomato
meter
too wide to ignore leading and overall
average by over 20 points
is so vast even dom himself might have
second thoughts about trying to
evil knievel his way over that canyon
fnf keeps improving but it'll need
another tank to catch tommy fleet feet
mission impossible wins round two and
we're tied at one to one
round three characters and now the round
that is so
jam-packed with recognizable faces
famous celebrities and
let's be honest cars that it should be
worth two points
how does one disseminate all of the
characters from 15 movies stacked from
head to toe with heroes
villains here as they become villains
villainous heroes and of course
auto mechanics how much time do we have
to do this
i have as much time as i want well i do
have an automobile skydiving class at
four so let's just jump right into
it just when you didn't think it could
get any better huh as emilio taught us
in the first mission impossible
it's best to not get too attached to
side characters in these types of flicks
yet for the most part our gaggle of
heroes has stayed relatively intact
starting with the lead dog
tom cruise as ethan hunt the super spy
of the modern era has more flash than
born
and a healthier liver than bond and it
also helps that he might be the biggest
movie star
of all time plus did i mention he does
his own stunts
like even the really really hard ones
that's tom someone needs to show tom
cruise all the deep fake vids of himself
online
we don't need you to do the stunts
anymore i promise what the hell is he
doing i find it best not to look
his team similarly his game for multiple
missions whenever the need arises
so we get the always great ving rhames
as luther simon pegg is benji
and more recently rebecca ferguson has
added a major shot in the arm to the
franchise
as isla faust notable pop-ins have also
been provided by jeremy renner paula
patton and maggie cue to name a few
meanwhile the brass running these ops or
chasing down ethan hunt after they think
he's betrayed his country yet again
which he probably hasn't
includes a-listers like angela bassett
and alec baldwin
however only michelle monaghan's
storyline is ethan's betrothed once he
gets out of the really hard mission
business
has been a through line in multiple
films as opposed to the fast and the
furious which lives by the creed that
once you're in the family
you're always a threat to return even if
we thought michelle rodriguez is a goner
dom and brian played by vin diesel and
paul walker respectively
kicked things into high gear originally
and the one-time criminal and former
officer
forged a lifelong bond that would see
them play hopscotch on both sides of the
law since
dom sis mia played by jordana brewster
also adds in the family angle
and the adopted extended fam includes
tyrese ludacris
and sung kang as han say what
this just went from mission impossible
to mission and freaking sanity
later iterations would see clutch
editions like gal gadot kurt russell
and vanessa kirby hey hey she's in uh
the mission impossible
too but the biggest shot in the arm was
a double doozy of dwayne the rock
johnson
and jason statham statham made his tease
debut in a post-credits scene
and the rocks started out chasing a
round dom in fast five
leading to an epic slugfest that we'll
talk about in the next round okay cool
but just as important as our heroes
or eventual heroes are the true bad guys
and gals of these worlds
brian t's takashi was a standout in
tokyo drift
you like the justin timberlake of japan
right as was luke evans in part six
the star power has only increased since
as everyone from jaman hunsu to charlize
theron
to idris elba have jumped into the fray
the villain side of things
is the first time we really see the fast
series
outpace mission impossible although mi
certainly has its share of memorable
turns
john boyd's double crossing in the debut
film philip seymour hoffman's
psychopathic owen davian in part 3
and henry cavill's double arm pump all
worked wonders to elevate the suspense
of those films what this round
ultimately boils down to
is two questions who do we root for more
and who do we care about
of course the audience is going to be
cheering for tom cruise if for no other
reason
we just want the guy to survive whatever
stunt he's currently attempting
but two is better than one and the
chemistry between vin and paul
began as a friendly rivalry got upgraded
to bromance and by the end
it felt like true brothers and that's
the key to question number two
who do we care about the families it's
nice to see the return of our faves from
mission impossible without a doubt
but i've been to other movies in
theaters and when a trailer
for a fast and furious film airs the
crowd cheers when it's revealed
who is returning for more hair brained
automotive action
so how do you all want to play this fast
both franchises have established an
extended network of reliable players
from stars down to occasional cameos
that any film series
or even studio for that matter would
adore but it's the depth to which we
care about our fast family that makes a
difference here and it's enough to get
them to win
in round number three for uh for one
point then they get one point
i know i know i thought about two but we
got through it in relatively good time
so
it's a 2-1 lead as we now hit the gas to
the penultimate round
i don't have friends i got family
round four robin is racing
here's where you keep us coming back for
more sure we love our movie stars but
without intense action
high-flying stunts and ridiculous car
jumping are we really gonna return to
see the next installment
is there anyone out there clamoring for
the pacifier too
how about another lions for lambs no we
prefer our movie stars to be in the most
dangerous positions on earth or at least
we want it to
look that way i'm jumping out a window
what do you mean you're jumping out of a
what started off as a fun street racing
movie has turned into a full-fledged
action serial that only ups the ante
every time out of the gate at this point
i would not be shocked if vin had to
outrun a t-rex
after all this is the franchise that
features the rock zooming around on an
iceberg
and opening his car door at 80 miles per
hour to gently nudge get this
an active torpedo in a different
direction
none of us blinked an eye why because we
wanted to see what was gonna happen
next boom baby fast and furious may have
evolved from its racing roots but it has
never forgotten where it started
tokyo drift may not be the highest rated
movie on the tomato meter but it still
holds up for its unique driving style
that still dazzles to this very day
you know what dk stands for
donkey kong brian and dom must have
known how much was riding on fast five
because
wow did they take it up a notch from
their car surfing off a cliff
to the bank heist which sees them using
an actual bank vault as a medieval
warning star to ward off their pursuers
that's the kind of batty genius that has
become these movie's signature
and speaking of fast five that dom hobbs
fight for action star supremacy
is an incredible display of stunt
coordination
and brute strength you can feel how much
dwayne hates when vin takes naps
from vertical skyscraper chases to
blowing up nuclear submarines to hobbs
and shaw's legendary prison brawl
fast and furious films never let us get
too far away from the next explosive
action sequence
and yes my favorite moment is still car
parachuting
it looks awesome it would make neil
degrasse tyson leave the theater
and yet vin diesel while his car is in
mid-air
still has his hand on the gearshift like
what are you downshifting to adjust for
wind
relax dude enjoy the ride dom have a
corona well no don't have a corona
and to say these scenes are ridiculous
is accurate but it doesn't mean that
mission impossible is the most
plausible action series in town there's
plenty of stuff that probably wouldn't
happen in real life but we give those
movies a pass
why because more often than not tom
cruise actually pulled off what we see
on the big screen
maybe not with people shooting at him or
an actual bazooka trying to take him out
but cliff jumping at the beginning of
mi2
check knife fight at the end of that
movie you're damn right
dangling on the side of the tallest
building on earth
and just another tuesday hanging out to
the side of an in-flight plane
i'm free this weekend it's all of those
maneuvers that make us take all the
motorcycle chases
building leaps and all-out sprints for
granted we've come a long way from
buzzing the tower maverick
and not to make it just a one-man show
the team has had some memorable fights
over the years
cattle cruise in the bathroom is the
best fight scene in close proximity to a
toilet since the raid 2.
ethan hunt has also taken on everyone
from miss faust to an entire helicopter
by the time
fallout came around and i'm gonna go
ahead and chalk up that suspenseful
langley scene as
an action sequence too it's just too
much fun to ignore
when comparing the two entities
imagination is at a premium with both
franchises
that's why us fans appreciate them so
much we trusted the filmmakers are
always looking to raise the bar
from the previous iteration in the case
of fast and furious that could mean
defying those buzzkill law of physics
even more
and for mission impossible that seeing
what tom cruise is able to sign off on
and that's why i lean towards ethan hunt
and his team in this round
it's nothing against fast and furious
but after a while you feel like they're
invincible
and they're always going to emerge
victorious with a few cool looking scars
not that ethan is any easier to kill he
may actually be tougher
but we know it's really tom pulling
those moves off
so while i do wish he would scale back
and you know preserve his ability to
keep making movies
i'm a hypocrite because i do appreciate
that he does not want his audience to
feel cheated
one of these days you're gonna take it
too far every movie in these two film
sets
have given us plenty of bang for our
buck but when the premium is on making
the most realistic looking action
sequences possible
and we still get the body levels of risk
taking then it's mission impossible
pulling off the win here in reality both
teams have great stunt crews that risk
their necks for our entertainment
and both utilize a ton of effects to
continue to pull off the magic tricks
credit goes to both but the point goes
the mission
oh hey we got us a tied ball game two to
two
and now it's time for our wild card
round gozer the destructor
yeah i couldn't resist in this round
everyone loves in movies when the chief
is yelling at various cops for how much
destruction they caused the city
even tom cruise himself gets reminded
how expensive
jets actually cost and that is the
taxpayers putting the bill
in top gun but no amount of super plane
fuel or city block
cost can equal the total dollars and
cents havoc
reeked by these two franchises thus i
invoke the name of gozer the
mythological ghostbusters destroyer to
help us consider
which franchise is responsible for more
total destruction
thanks to both that ancient evil entity
and our expert researcher mark hoffmeyer
for crunching the numbers on this
yes kids we have actual numbers data
intel and um it reaches the billions
billions helicopters ain't cheap and
when they explode in a tunnel it may be
thrilling but it also provides a massive
bill for someone to clean up the very
next day
and that first mission impossible's
total destruction pans out to around two
million dollars
does that sound like a lot it's not
because there's vehicles and especially
the 747
of mi2 that yielded a loss of about
50 million dollars these are actual
estimates folks
the fast and the furious limited the
damage initially to about 120 grand out
of the gate
because you know we had to return most
of those cars from once they came
but then in too fast too furious we
start wrecking cop cars and crushing
yachts like it's a music video in step
brothers
all making for a total of five million
bucks
still that somehow feels modest and when
compared to the thousands of sports cars
and oh
a nuclear submarine in the fate of the
furious it's peanuts
you are right the eighth installment of
this series takes the top prize in terms
of franchise total destruction
equaling 2.9 billion dollars
that number is only matched by mission
impossible's ghost protocol
and no it's not the tall building scene
or the ensuing sandstorm or the water
tank
look it's quicker if i just tell you the
kremlin it's a real place
and it's where we first see our hero in
action part of it blows up
and depending on how much was destroyed
the estimate is it's three billion
dollars worth of damage
the building is nice the priceless art
and artifacts
well it turns out i guess they do have a
price tag rogue nation would primarily
rack up motorcycle and car expenses then
fallout took out a couple airbus 125s
adding in tom cruise's quick hospital
trip that would be about seven million
dollars total it's a close ball game
until you consider the fast spin off
hobbs and shaw
we got wrecked cars helicopters
buildings and oh yeah
chernobyl plus we got to factor in the
price tag of making an
evolutionary leap forward with black
superman that may look like idris elba
but it's also a 200 million dollar super
soldier
that film alone would have yielded two
billion dollars worth of damage
jesus christ whereas the cartoonish
nature of some of the fast and furious
action sequences
might have penalized it in round four no
such worries here
the louder the explosions and the bigger
the blast the more billions you're
racking up
the total for the franchises are as
follows mission impossible rounds up to
3.1 billion dollars
man it is a good thing they went to
russia but the fast and the furious
would have been responsible for 5.4
billion bucks worth of damage
that is not good for your bottom line
but their losses become
our gains and with that it's the furious
folks that are fast
that take the round and thus win the
match
it don't matter if you win by an inch or
a mile
that's right winning's winning
and that's how it shakes out kiddies the
fast franchise owes 2.5 billion dollars
more than mission impossible
so i figured a win here is the least i
can do joke as i may it is nothing short
of jaw-dropping to see a mission
impossible film on the big imac screen
making your jaw hit all the way to the
ground is the knowledge that tom cruise
captain a-list
is performing these stunts himself we
hope he's around to give us many more
years of thrills chills and cries of why
tom y meanwhile we might also be
screaming why
dom why when he cannot resist yet
another mission that will no doubt
put him and his crew in final jeopardy
he may never be killed off in his
franchise
but those shirts are definitely getting
stains thanks for watching the show
today
and stick around for tons more quality
entertainment related content right here
at rotten tomatoes
and hit me up on social media at mark
ellis live
and let us know which movie series is
your favorite the ones with
mostly vin diesel are the ones with
always tom cruise
until next time my name is mark and this
vid will self-destruct
in five four three two
remember inspector gadget they did the
uh they did the same gag
anyway we're done here and i got a hot
2020 ford fusion to
drift back to the valve
you